طيب في احد كتبك حددت الصين باعتبارها
الدوله الاكثر تاثيرا في هذا المجال لو
تشرح لي اكثر عن هذا الموضوع
مره اخرى
انا اتحدث عن علومي والتكنولوجيا
لا اريد ان اخور في المجالات الاخرى مصادر
الاخرى فقط العلوم والتكنولوجيا ولكن فقط
في هذا المجال فان النقاش حول ما تقوم به
الصين قد يملا مجلدات كامله وفي الحقيقه
بالفعل ملات مجلدات كامله فهي تدير مراكز
خاصه بالعلوم والتكنولوجيا والمعلومات
الاستخباراتيه ويسمى
المعلومات العلميه والتكنولوجيه منذ خمسين
القرن الماضي وعدد اكبر يعملون في هذا
المجال وهذه العمليات اكثر من القوى
العامله لكافه الوكاله الاستخباريه في
العالم مجتمعه الى هذه الدرجه تاخذ الصين
هذه المساله بجديه ولكن الفارق الاساسي
بين عمليات الصين
او مثلا الولايات المتحده الى جانب
الارقام غير متكافئه هي ان الولايات تقوم
بهذه العمليات لمراقبه التهدئه
التكنولوجيه نحن نحصل على المعلومات ولا
نمررها الى الشركات
وهذا الجدل سبق وان حصل وهذا ليس بالشيء
الذي نقوم به ولا نرغب ان نقوم به اما
الصين
فتدير برامج عن قبل الدوله لتعاقب
التكنولوجيا الاجنبيه والعلامه استخبار
المعلومات هي جزء اساسي من برامج التي
تديرها
لكن هل كل الاساليب الصينيه
يمكننا ان نقول انها مثيره للجدل او غير
قانونيه مثل قرصنه وسرقه وغيرها
هذا هو مجرد دائر تمت الجبل الجليدين فان
عملياتها القرصنه والسرقه وكل اشياء غير
القانونيه هي جزء من
عده الصيني للحيازه حيازه التكنولوجيا
العالميه ولكنها ليست الاداه الاهم
مجال تتميز فيه الصين هي الحيازات في
المنطقه الرماديه وهي الحوالات الماليه
غير الخاضعه للرقابه
وقانونيتها غير معروفه
تعرفنا على اكثر من 12 فئه من هذا القبيل
مثلا العمليات او الحوالات غير الاخلاقيه
سواء عن طريق الرشاوه او البرامج الدوليه
سيئه السمعه والمشاريع التعاونيه احاديه
الجانب وكذلك استغلال الصين المهجرين او
جاريه المهجره
كتبا بهذه المعلومات كتاب مثل هذا
الا في دول اخرى ايضا تستهدفها الصين
تستهدف كافه الدول المتقدمه من اجل
التكنولوجيات وحالات تخسر امكانيه الوصول
الى التكنولوجيا في دوله مثلا الولايات
المتحده وبعد ذلك تبدا
بالتعويضه في دول اخرى ولكن يجب ان نكون
مستطيل فان نقل التكنولوجيا سؤال قانون او
غير الاخلاقي هذه ممارسه عالميه والكل
يقوم بذلك اما الصين فهي تفعل ذلك اكثر من
غيرها وافضل من غيرها ايضا بس كيف بتم
تحويل التكنولوجيا المستورده اذا كانت
مستورده او مسروقه حتى الى منتجات في
الصين هذا هو السؤال
هذا سؤال وجيه هو
المحل المستقبل ياتيون
بحثوا فيه كثيرا ويبدو ان الصين لديها
شبكه
فيها حوالي 900
منتجعات التكنولوجيه مدعومه من قبل الدوله
لديهم اسماء مختلفه لهذه المجمعات
والارقام ربما اكثر من 900 الان ولكنها
موجوده فقط
لاستغلال هذه التكنولوجيا على الصعيد
التجاري او حتى لتحويلها الى اسلحه
واستخدامك اسلحه وهذا مجمعات
احجام مختلفه تماما من مباني فيها عده
طوابق او حتى اماكن فيها عدد صغير من
الاشخاص وهنا تاتي عمليه التحويل هذه
التكنولوجيا الى المجال التجاري